la 20e édition de la nuit en course
s'est soldé dimanche 7 avril par la
victoire sur le 10 km de nicolas
petitjean de le à 50 ans en 32 minutes
et 49 secondes
il termine avec plus d'une minute
d'avancé sur son principal adversaire et
s'était déjà imposé l'an dernier
quelques 450 participants étaient
présents sur la ligne de départ il ya
une côte vers le 6e kilomètre qui
généralement
attaque plutôt bien et généralement
c'est là où on fait un peu la différence
avec les concurrents j'avais décidé en
fait d'attaquer 6e kilomètre je me suis
rendu compte que
mes concurrents avaient un petit peu de
mal 24e donc c'est à partir du 4e où je
suis parti
et puis j'ai réussi à maintenir le
rythme mais je serais content d'avoir
gagné aujourd'hui un départ en descente
sur 2000 mètres avant de négocier cette
fameuse côté de terminer sur un faux
plat au stade des droits de l'homme ce
rendez vous annuel à guyancourt se
voulait tout de même accessible au plus
grand nombre
à l'opposé du marathon de paris qui se
tenait au même moment ceux qui
participent au marathon de paris se
prépare à peu près entre 6 et 8 semaines
à l'avancé et c'est pas du tout les
mêmes types de de fourrure cette course
et surtout une course un peu familial
c'est à dire que tout le monde peut
participer un 10 km sans avoir un
entraînement très très intensifs le club
organisateur prépare à présent son
prochain rendez-vous le 10km nocturne à
elancourt ce sera le 1er juin dès 20h